[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily we
ask you to give Mr Depp his life back
by telling the world that Mr death is
not the abuser misheard said he is and
hold misheard accountable for her life
closing arguments are presented in the
case of Johnny Depp versus Amber Heard
and Deb's team calls herds allegations a
vicious lie Ms heard's claim that the
op-ed is not about Mr Depp it's just
another one of her many many lives plus
Amber heard's attorneys fight for their
client and you cannot simultaneously
protect and uphold the First Amendment
and find in favor of Johnny Depp on his
plane you simply cannot and later a
breakdown of Amber hearn's counterclaim
you can find whatever Mr waldman's done
and you can find whatever Mr Depp has
done and both of those are the same for
purposes of evaluating the verdict form
law on crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
foreign
to lawn crime daily I'm your host Brian
buckmeyer closing arguments in the
Johnny Depp versus Amber Heard case are
presented six years to the day after
Amber Heard filed for a temporary
restraining order from then husband
Johnny Depp
Vaughn crimes Angela Levy was inside the
courtroom for closing arguments Friday
Anjanette
Brian you know it was May 27 2016 when
Amber Heard went to the courthouse in
Los Angeles and filed for that domestic
relations domestic violence restraining
order against Johnny Depp you know this
was a turning point for Johnny Depp this
is when his attorneys say the giant lie
began the paparazzi was at the
courthouse and this made international
news
so let's talk about the giant lie at the
heart of this case
Miss Hertz claim that Mr Depp is an
abusive monster
and that she is a public figure
representing domestic abuse
at the start of this case Mr Chu and I
told you that you were going to hear
some disturbing and graphic Tales of
abuse from misheard
and they were designed to shock you and
overwhelm you
we told you that this would be a
performance the role of her lifetime
as a heroic Survivor of brutal abuse
when Mr Depp brought this case for
defamation misheard went all in she spun
a story of shocking overwhelming brutal
abuse
she came into this courtroom prepared to
give the performance of her life and she
gave it Miss heard's acting coach
Christina Sexton testified that misheard
has difficulty crying when she is acting
you saw it misheard sobbing without
tears while spinning elaborate
exaggerated Fantastical accounts of
abuse and everything going on in her
mind almost a decade prior while
enduring that abuse
it was a performance
she told you what she thinks you need to
hear to convict this man as a domestic
abuser and a rapist
and Camille Vasquez didn't mention this
in her closing argument but it had come
up in testimony during the trial May
27th is not only the date that Amber
Heard requested that domestic violence
restraining order it's also the birthday
of Johnny Depp's daughter Lily Rose and
we heard testimony that Lily Rose did
not like Amber Heard so you have to
wonder if that date was purely a
coincidence giving given what's being
alleged in this case by the depth team
that this was all an elaborate hoax
Brian
imagine that so you were in the
courtroom tell us about what you heard
in the lawyer's voice as they argued in
summation the reaction of the jury and
even the audience has closing arguments
were being made
you know I think it was uh interesting
because I've been in the courtroom
obviously before and this was different
um you know it's a serious mood in there
all at all times but this felt heavier
this morning for some reason it felt
more serious and you know I don't know
how to describe it it was just a heavy
feeling and everybody was very quiet
there have been some times where people
have you know chit-chatted and things
like that but it was just really quiet
and then Camille Vasquez got up to start
her closing argument the jurors smiled
at her pretty broadly and then they
listened they listened intently I didn't
see any of them taking notes which was
interesting because they took a lot of
notes obviously during the trial and
during the testimony but they seemed
very engaged in what she had to say but
they've been a lot of them have been
kind of stone-faced and I felt like they
were pretty stone-faced to do today as
well at least from where I was sitting
yeah now I think I guess this is a
million dollar question when do you
think will get a verdict and what issue
do you think the jury will grapple with
the most uh when trying to come up with
a heads or tails of this case
I need to make predictions about
verdicts sometimes I'm right and
sometimes I'm wrong you know it's kind
of like spitballing but you know there's
just no telling a judge asked karate
told the jurors she would let them
deliver it into the evening if they if
they wished but but she also told them I
don't order dinner so be aware of that
also we are on the you know cusp of a
holiday weekend it's Memorial Day
weekend so you have to wonder is this
jury really going to want to stay at the
courthouse late also there was a woman
dismissed from the jury along with a man
so that means there are two women now on
this jury and five men and there are
some you know there are different age
ranges involved here some of these are
younger men and the women one of the
women appeared to be kind of in her
maybe in her 50s and then there was a
younger woman so
um you know people have different life
experiences it's really it's really hard
to understand or wonder or put
yourselves in their shoes to wonder what
their where you know what they're
dealing with and what they're focusing
on absolutely well we're all curious
about what they're focusing on Angela
stick with us we'll be back in a moment
still ahead on Law and crime daily a
closer look at the closing argument
presented for Johnny Depp
this case for Mr Devon has never been
about
it
is
about Mr Depp's reputation
freeing him from the prison in which he
has lived for the last six years and
it's six years to the day
I had the accumulation of the Johnny
Depp Amber Heard trial as Attorney
Benjamin Chu rounds out closing
Arguments for Deb's side
[Music]
welcome back to Long crime daily we're
taking a closer look now at Depp's
closing argument
presented in part by Attorney Ben chu
chu told jurors Deb's reputation is
forever tarnish because of a vicious lie
thank you
Mr Depp has millions of fans people who
have who
grew up watching him on 21 Jump Street
which is something you heard Miss heard
mock on one of the tapes that was
applied to you
or they grew up watching him play the
swashbuckling pirate Captain Jack
Sparrow and the Pirates of the Caribbean
movies or Willy Wonka Mr Depp means
something to those people
and those people mean a lot to Mr death
he's a fond memory from childhood or
adolescence or adulthood and to tarnish
him as an abuser
is to destroy him in the eyes of many of
these people who will never look at him
the same way again and because of what
misheard did and because of what she
said Mr Depp will go to his grave
knowing matter knowing no matter what he
does no matter the outcome of this trial
there are people who used to look up to
him who now believe that he beat a woman
which is the worst thing you can say
about a man he did not and does not
deserve to have his life his legacy
destroyed by a vicious lie the lies have
grown and metastasized over time
and they need to be stopped and those
false accusations have caused more harm
to Mr Depp than her fists ever did
joining us today is defense attorney
Matthew mangino co-host Terry Austin and
Lawn crime correspondent Anjanette Levy
Matt I was actually not a fan of this
argument by chew I actually expected
her's lawyers to argue that some people
can separate their childhood love of
characters like Jack Sparrow and that's
maybe why they are lying on his behalf
but that didn't happen so my question
for you is was this closing convincing
enough to sway a juror that may believe
heard
well there's a couple of things that I
was concerned about with regard to this
closing number one is this idea of hero
worship I mean they're almost condoning
that hey people love Johnny Depp and
they'll do anything for Johnny Depp and
they'll say anything for for Johnny Depp
the other problem is that they said that
his reputation is forever tarnished well
you're not going to get your reputation
back if it's forever tarnished so this
is about money and they're trying to say
on one hand hey this isn't about money
it's about his reputation but you've
already conceded that his reputation is
tarnished and he's never going to get it
back so what is this case about uh so it
was an interesting sort of dichotomy in
in their closing that that struck me uh
kind of strange yeah I thought they had
a lot of strong arguments there and they
kind of passed on them Terry do you
think how Vasquez and true divided the
closing work to their benefit
I do I think it was a great strategy we
know that Camille Vasquez focused on
Amber hurt she walked that jury through
what happened one thing I said before
and I'll say it again I think they
should have had a demonstrative to show
what dates things happened and what the
claims were but she walked them through
it and she showed that jury that she
lied the entire time and I think that
made sense because it was Camille
Vasquez who cross-examined Amber Heard
and then I think it made total sense for
Ben Chu to actually do the law to talk
about what it takes to find defamation
and to also walk the jury through the
verdict form that's critical so they
understand what they are looking at when
they get behind closed doors yeah and
Jack what's going on in Fairfax County
Virginia has anything else happened in
or outside the courthouse since the jury
got the case
you know the only thing that's really
happened Brian you know as we've been
telling you each day people when Johnny
Depp leaves the courthouse they line the
street behind the courthouse and they
cheer for him he waves the crowds have
been huge and they've just grown since
the beginning of the trial that crowd
then kind of migrates to the front of
the courthouse and they're gathered
there right now and they are waiting for
the lawyers for Johnny Depp's leaders to
exit the courthouse so they've been
doing this as well coming to show
support for his attorneys we don't see
that same level of support for Amber
Heard and her lawyers they leave a
different way all right let's see what
happens with this crowd as we go into
verdict watch waiting to see how this
jury I think you said five men and two
women decide this case thank you very
much Anjanette coming up on Law and
crime daily the Johnny Depp Amber Heard
defamation trial inches towards the
finish line
this trial is about so much more than
Johnny Depp versus Amber Heard
it's about the freedom of speech stand
up for it protect it and reject Mr
Depp's claims against Amber
up next Amber heard's attorneys take the
floor to present their summation of the
case before the jury
[Music]
foreign
arguments from Amber heard's attorneys
Jay Benjamin rottenborn told the jury
Deb's team is victim blaming and that
this case is about the First Amendment
and freedom of speech
trying to convince you that Mr death has
carried his burden of proof improving
that he was never abusive to Amber on
even one occasion
think about the message that Mr death
and his attorneys are sending to Amber
and by extension to every victim of
domestic abuse everywhere
if you didn't take pictures it didn't
happen
if you did take pictures
they're fake
if you didn't tell your friends you're
lying
and if you did tell your friends they're
part of the hoax and if you finally
decide that enough is enough
you've had enough of the fear enough of
the pain and you have to leave to save
yourself you're a gold digger your key
question to answer is does the First
Amendment give misheard the right to
write the words that she wrote in this
article
on December 18 2018. that's the question
and you cannot simultaneously protect
and uphold the First Amendment and find
in favor of Johnny Depp on his claim you
simply cannot
you have to decide should someone be
able to write an article like that in
the United States of America without
being sued successfully without having
to go through the hell that Missouri has
gone through it is time to tell Mr Depp
that this was his last chance
tell him to move on with his life
tell him to let Amber move on with hers
stand up for the freedom of speech
stand up for the First Amendment
Terry maybe it's the criminal defense
attorney in me but arguing burdens first
when your client is an alleged victim of
intimate partner violence felt like a
weak start to a closing to me what did
you think
you know I totally understand your point
but I think it was actually a clever way
to flip the narrative I was impressed by
the way he laid that out he told the
jury if you believe depth then you're
sending a message to Amber and others
who are true victims that unless you
have photographs unless you have tapes
unless you went to the physician unless
all of these things then it didn't
happen now the problem there is you
start thinking well hmm maybe that's
true but here Amber Heard said so many
lies she's not a true victim if you
believe that all of these are lies so if
she were a true victim then those issues
would be a problem and I did think it
was pretty clever the way he flipped
that switch on that jury to make the
depth team look like they were trying to
hide something you know I see that
switch Works Matt the strongest part of
heard's case at least in my opinion is
that Ron Moore is right to say that the
jury only needs to believe one act of
violence occurred but do all jurors have
to agree on the same alleged act and is
that possible
I don't think that that's the case uh
here
um Brian because this isn't a criminal
case where you have to prove the
elements of say aggravated assault you
know an intent to cause serious bodily
injury and it has to be obviously a
specific act here this is a defamation
case and what he what uh Johnny Depp's
position is is that he's never abused
Amber Heard and therefore anything that
she said is defamatory when it comes to
abuse and if you can prove whether it be
one instance of abuse or one instance
that one person believes in another
instance that another person believes on
that jury that's going to be enough
because you don't have to prove a
specific element of abuse that you
normally would or or assault that you
normally would in a criminal prosecution
now that makes a lot of sense my only
question is was that clear enough to the
jury and how long is going to take for
them to kind of parse through that we
might be here for some days but we'll be
here following each and every step when
we come back Amber heard's counterclaim
explained Plus
creating a hoax or creating any of this
or making any of this up that's a big
question here
heard's closing argument presented by
Elaine brendanov
welcome back to law and crime daily as
part of her's closing argument Elaine
brendenhoff narrowed in on the counter
claim and the statements made by Depp's
attorney Adam Walton
with respect to the malice on this one
you know he knows that he did these
things you know that he knows he was out
of it for three days and that's all that
we need to prove for mounts but there's
a couple of more facts here but you can
find whatever Mr waldman's done and you
can find whatever Mr Depp has done and
both of those are the same for purposes
of evaluating the verdict form they
stand in each other's shoes when you
have an agent and that's what the jury
instructions say you can go with both
what did Mr Waldman do there was an
article about the sexual violence that
he had put from the April one that went
into the trial Amber's testimony she was
sitting near him in the trial Adam
Waldman through that newspaper down in
front of her defiantly that's actual
malice remember he's the one that after
the UK trial went to the LAPD with a
notebook full of things and tried to get
perjury charges is against Amber
the LAPD said we don't investigate those
things but he then went to a German
newspaper and said Amber is being
investigated by the NYPD or the LAPD for
perjury do you remember that that's
malice that's showing his intent to do
harm to Amber he also admitted that he
speaks to that umbrella guy and you'll
see that one text in there from the
person from TMZ that umbrella guy is the
big lead of Johnny Depp's you know
positive uh social media that is putting
all the negative out on Amber Amber
Heard and he also ended up getting
knocked out of Twitter because he was
abusing Amber
Jersey finished deliberating on Friday
just after two hours of having the case
they'll be back on Tuesday at 9 00 a.m
eastern time to continue with
deliberations make sure to stay with law
and crying Network for a live broadcast
when jury questions and ultimately the
verdict is read
Matt brendelhoff's definition of actual
malice was actually off could that hurt
her when the jury compares the
definition to her arguments while
deliberating
well um you know it is a bit off but you
know as long as the court doesn't give a
Curative instruction I don't believe
there is going to be any Curative
instruction uh about the way she
presented that during her closing then I
don't think the jury is going to focus
much attention on it in fact they're
trying to figure out what their
responsibility is right now I mean you
have very detailed jury instructions uh
you have 23 days of testimony you have
these closing arguments you have all
these things swirling in their head I
think they're they're going to be more
focused on some of the fundamental
issues in this case than to get
distracted by what may have not been a
completely accurate definition although
we all know that in law school they
teach us you know child uh trial
advocacy one-on-one you know don't uh
you know misquote the the statute uh
because that's can always come back and
be harmful to your case but here I don't
think in the grand scheme thing it's
going to make that much of a difference
to jurors all right we'll see when the
jurors coming out Terry Brenda Hoff
seemed to rush through her closing
understandably because they only had six
minutes for rebuttal how will time
management affect this trial
management affects everything Brian
listen we know for
her team too much time during the trial
and during the closing and when you have
to run it's not as important to the jury
so they should have saved some of that
time all right well rushing out of here
now as well thank you both and thank you
for joining us here along crime daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
Justice in America
foreign
[Music]